good morning to our viewers I'm Michelle
Miller and we're in the CBS this morning
Toyota greenroom with the dietitian
Samantha Heller she's here to discuss
the latest diet craze this thing called
the keto diet and I have to tell you not
everybody's heard about this thing but
it is a bonafide craze these days what's
the science behind it how does it work
if you know it is it crazy I get a lot
of calls on my Sirius XM radio show like
what do you think about keto and the
ketogenic diet was developed about a
hundred years ago and it's used for
children with seizure disorders like
epilepsy really yeah so it's a very high
high high fat diet about 90% fat so
breakfast might be heavy whipping cream
and some mayonnaise and 2 or 3 teaspoons
of butter and a slice of bacon I mean
way high fat and the theory behind it is
that it alters your brain metabolism to
help decrease seizures in children and
there is some efficacy behind this
meaning they did see some success with
children this is recalling that movie
Lorenzo's oil and the true life story
behind it the young boy had a
debilitating disease in this high-fat
diet this oil really helped him along am
I on the same plane with this or no I
don't remember what he was diagnosed
with and what kind of oil they used so
I'm not sure if it's exactly the same
physiological biochemical process but
what your brain loves sugar
it loves glucose and that's the primary
source of fuel for your brain so if you
deprive your brain of that food of
glucose by not eating any carbohydrate
or virtually none your brain is going to
find an emergency source and that is
that soy source is burning fat and it
comes from what we call fat fat
oxidation and then you that creates
something called a ketone and the ketone
body or the ketone is what's used for
fuel it is not optimal but for children
with epilepsy they did find that it was
somewhat helpful in terms of weight loss
not a lot of evidence in humans
suggesting that it's helpful or that it
works for the long term that it's
sustainable so it sounds like you're
saying you're not completely
on this new fad I'm not sold on it at
all it's it's not healthy
you know you there's no fiber there's no
vegetables there's almost no fruit
there's no beans there's nuts no seeds
no healthy grains it's not a balanced
healthy approach now people say well it
works for me well what does that mean it
worked I lost weight can you keep it off
is it sustainable are you healthy are
you healthy is the biggest question we
want to ask now are you skinny are you
healthy and over time if you stay on a
diet like that you're not going to be
healthy because you're not getting all
of the different nutrients your body
needs to be healthy for optimal health
to fight disease we've been through this
before we've seen it with the Atkins
diet with this this other diet called
whole xxx the Paleo diet I've even done
one called the B diet and they're
variations of this but what seems to be
an interesting thought is that there's a
fasting period you only eat what six to
eight hours a day is is is that really
the key behind part of what we have
going on here well I don't know that
it's necessarily relevant to specific
diets but there is a newer approach to
eating styles called intermittent
fasting got it and that means it's got a
variety of meanings that as you
suggested where you don't eat for eight
hours a day you don't eat for ten hours
you eat low-calorie every other day so
there's many variations of it and the
research is suggesting that there may be
some benefits for some people it may
lower blood glucose levels and people
with diabetes they may help people
manage their weight or calories better I
don't love some of those variations
because first of all we're already doing
intermittent fasting because at night we
sleep right hopefully we're not up in
the middle of the night eating right but
if you're sleeping for eight hours six
hours you're not eating so we're already
giving our body that rest it needs to
get itself organized for the next day
physiologically I don't know that we
need to do that every day and I think
that the people who really want to do it
who are desperate to lose weight or were
desperate to lower their cholesterol or
lower their blood glucose they already
have a complicated relationship with
food so when
you're depriving someone of food for a
day or very low calorie
it feels punitive it doesn't feel good
and how long can you do that but that's
the point a lot of these people are
doing it for a short period of time
anywhere between a week to a month yeah
with the sole purpose of losing weight
and if they lose weight and that was
their goal in the end in the long run is
it not necessarily a bad thing or I
usually gain it back that's the question
I gained it back so the goal at least my
goal when I work with patients this is
to say let's craft a plan an eating plan
with foods you like in proper portions
throughout the day that help you eat
healthy get all the nutrients your body
needs to function really well at high
speed optimal levels fight disease and
manage your weight and it is doable but
it takes some thought it is not sexy and
it takes it takes time and it tastes
really it takes time because these diets
offer you quick weight loss right and
that's the sexiness of it oh yeah and we
like extremes we want high protein only
no bread or what we yeah an affinity we
love that for a while because we'd like
that extreme I'm not sure why we like
that extreme but in some ways as you
said it's easier Brahe don't have to
think about it you don't have to make a
lot of decisions we make over 200
decisions about food a day and many of
us think about food even more than that
so to cut that back and not have to
think so much about it people like that
it's just not always the best way in the
healthiest way to approach an eating
pattern so everybody from like Halle
Berry to Vanessa Hudgens to LeBron James
to I'm cheating here yech the
Kardashians and even Tim Tebow have
tried the keto diet or at least gone on
the record it would be interesting to
hear from them to see if they are
completely sold in that long run sort of
you know yeah for at now is it is
certainly not optimal for athletes
because the primary source of fuel for
your exercising muscle is glucose and
that comes from carbohydrates and
carbohydrates aren't just pasta and
bread and potatoes and crackers and
cereal
they are fruits and vegetables
and even beans so carbohydrates or
anything that once digested primarily
turns to glucose glucose is an okay
thing sugars not toxic
it keeps our bodies alive it keeps our
bodies fueled but portion is everything
and I think the quality of the food
matters so the other thing I think that
what happens to a lot of people who do
these fad diets do they the question is
do they do they trick their body into a
more fat conscious mode so that when
they're off the diet does their body
have a sense to create more fat do they
do their body harm going in and out of
these these these diets I think what
you're referring to is yo-yo dieting
yeah yeah that would be a good word to
describe it and what the research
suggests is when you do yo-yo dieting
which is you die you lose weight you go
off the diet you gain the weight you
diet you know yo-yoing back and forth
that over time your body starts to
become more efficient at storing fat
because it doesn't know when the next
meal is coming from so if you purposely
don't eat a lot of calories every day
for many days your body doesn't know
you're doing it on purpose it only knows
it's not getting the fuel it needs to be
healthy
remember your body's job is to stay
alive 24/7 and it's going to do
everything it can to keep you alive it
doesn't know why you're restricting
certain foods or why you're low in
vitamin B or vitamin C it just knows
what it has to deal with from what you
put or don't put in your mouth so the
body's wisdom is stay alive it doesn't
understand why it's not being fed and if
it's not getting food it gets scared
right so it's like oh my gosh I'm not
getting the fuel I need to stay alive so
I'm gonna slow down so then I'm gonna
chill out and then it does something
else it's really cool when you start
eating again
it makes food taste better than it ever
did before to get you to eat more
because it doesn't know when the next
food meal is coming so your body is
brilliant and we and let's work with
that brilliance to keep our bodies alive
and not fight against it so the take
away eat a balanced nutritious diet but
not in the traditional diet sense try to
make it what a part of your life well as
a lifestyle I like to call Edie I
haven't been mentioned
eating patterns you know we don't just
eat a single nutrient as I said you know
before you don't just sit down and eat
up a the plate of saturated fat or a
plate of vitamin C you mean food right
and we know that the foods that come
from the plant world are really healthy
for us and this research is suggesting
these very large epidemiological studies
are suggesting that more plant-based
diets are healthier for us for so many
many reasons so think twice before you
move to one of those diets yeah yeah
that's that's your takeaway
that's my well my takeaway is also if
you're confused and and you just don't
want to have the guesswork see a
registered dietician a registered
dietician we're highly trained we were
spend a lot of time in the school
studying biochemistry in Physiology and
medicine we can help you craft an eating
plan that works with your budget your
food preferences your lifestyle what if
you're a student what if you have to get
up at 3 in the morning to be on
television we can help you do that so
it's not quite so much guesswork and
your own physiology I wanted to move on
to another topic you came on CBS this
morning to discuss and that was the
whole buzz about coconut oil and how a
Harvard study of a Harvard professor
rather came out and said it is poison to
your body what's your take on that I
don't understand why she said that
I mean coconut oil is a saturated fat
and that refers to the molecular
structure so it's really confusing and
very complicated but what we know from a
lot of studies for decades is that a
diets they're high in this type of fat
increase the risk in particular for
cardiovascular disease and so coconut
oil is in that category it has an
undeserved health halo it doesn't cure
cancer it doesn't necessarily prevent
cognitive decline or Alzheimer's disease
we don't have evidence to suggest or to
support those claims right now you know
in the future we might on the other hand
coconut oil tastes really good and you
can cook at high temperatures with it so
if you want to make a coke a dish with
coconut oil or coconut milk it's fine
but just once in a while I was taught
when I was living in East Africa
coconuts are very plentiful but their
various stages in which they're more
that the coconut is
we're healthy for you the coconut water
is the optimal stage they told us drink
the coconut water it's better than like
the real h2o they said at the point at
which it becomes like buttery it's
moving into that high fat concentration
and the hard coconut when it is
completely that hard it's no longer even
that gel that's when you want to stay as
far away from it as possible did they
say why well they just said that the
maturation of the coconut was I mean the
really the optimal prime time to or the
rapist for nutrition was when it was in
the water stage well because there's no
fat in the water right it's coconut
water it's high in potassium which which
is great it helps lower blood pressure
but the coconut meat itself I mean I
love I've always loved coconut you just
have to use it sparingly like you would
butter awesome okay so we know that how
does it compare to those other oils like
olive and canola give us a quick rundown
of that so what we want to do is we want
to avoid fats that are solid at room
temperature so coconut oil is solid at
room temperature and so is butter and
dairy fat and bacon fat and chicken fat
so solid at room temperature means it's
saturated unsaturated is liquid at room
temperature so what else are liquid at
room temperature olive oil canola oil
avocado oil peanut oil soy oil those are
liquid at room temperature
and those are the ones we want to eat or
consume more of now a tablespoon of
olive oil and a tablespoon of butter
which do you think has more calories
tell me they're about the same really
yeah because they're both fats got a
nine calories a gram so calorically
they're the same pretty similar but the
unsaturated ones just offer more health
benefits quickly the New England Journal
of Medicine came out on fish oil and I
was told fish oil is a cure-all
certainly really good for your thyroid
gland but the study is saying maybe not
so well this study was it called the
Ascend study and it was looking at over
15,000 people who had type 2 diabetes
and they looked to see
taking about a gram a day of fish oil
lowered their risk of certain
cardiovascular disease markers and in
the end of the study which was about
seven and a half years which is long for
study in a big sample size they didn't
find a big difference a statistical
difference however the group that did
take the fish oil did have a 21 percent
lower risk of cardiovascular disease
now fish oil or the omega-3 fatty acids
which is really what we're referring to
is one of the most studied nutrients
around and it's important for health and
it does seem to have health benefits for
coronary heart disease also it's
important for healthy eyes and a healthy
brain and healthy fetal development so
it's great to have it in your diet it
doesn't mean you have to take a
supplement it's found in fatty fish like
salmon but in plant foods it's in
walnuts and soy and ground flax meal
it's a it's an essential oil so we have
to eat it to get it in our system and
your body needs it to be healthy so the
supplement is not as good as as the real
thing out of the whole food well the
supplements are okay if it's if they're
if they're a valid supplement you can
look for the USP seal on the bottle to
make sure it is what it says it is
because it's not regulated supplements
aren't regulated by the FDA the way
medical drugs are and some people need
supplements I had my omega-3 fatty acid
level tested and it was really really
low so I started taking a supplement oh
yeah so people may not eat seafood you
may not eat fish which is a good source
so for some people I think supplements
may be warranted this particular case
was looking at a marker of
cardiovascular disease and people with
diabetes but there are many other health
benefits to omega-3 fatty acids in our
diet people with thyroid conditions
certainly I don't know about the
evidence for that so I'm not sure about
thyroid I'm just here to take one out
for me okay good it worked for me in a
big way so I want to thank you you are
amazing thank you sir yeah a dietician
Samantha Heller we appreciate you
joining us thank you